so we've had a lot of bad news and kind
of things to be bummed out about on
today's show but one thing that really
brought a smile to my face was joe
biden's white house press secretary jen
saki just not caring anymore when it
comes to fox news reporter peter ducey
and pointing out to him that the jig is
up
she realizes that the dumb questions
peter ducey asks during press briefings
are just to try to get one of those
absurd segments on fox news where the
title around the bottom of the screen is
some kind of
of an attack either on joe biden or on
jen saki herself
and so she's just not going for it and
uh peter ducey tried to ask this
completely meaningless question
saying oh you know with trump it was the
art of the deal but with joe biden
it was going to be this other thing
related to infrastructure negotiations
and saki was just having none of it take
a look at this
describe the infrastructure negotiations
as the art of
seeking common ground at some point does
that become the art of the deal
i don't know i you're the professional
here peter you're the tv star
you know what's the fox chiron gonna be
uh art of seeking common ground does
take a lot of characters
the art of the of the deal we'd be okay
with that
yeah with the art of the deal i think
that's a headline well there you go an
art of a different kind of deal a deal
for the working people
got it okay go ahead so i'm glad we
could work that out thank you very much
the feel of peter ducey's questions
is that he's trying to play reporter and
jen saki humors him almost like he's not
really competent
but she just has to pretend to treat him
as if he were a competent reporter and
the really funny thing
is i think he's supposed to be seen as
asking tough questions like what
when he does this stuff i think there's
a contingent of the fox news audience
that sees that and says wow he's really
there and he's asking tough questions
but the questions are so silly and
childish
and not actually uh serious in any way
that gen saki and even joe biden
seem to enjoy taking questions from
peter like if it were actually the case
that this guy was asking such tough
questions and putting them in such
difficult positions
they wouldn't be so eager to hear from
him they almost seem entertained
by it and uh it's almost a curiosity to
see what flaccid nonsense
peter ducey's going to come up with next
and you get the feeling that gen saki
treats peter ducey and in some cases
that newsmax reporter named emerald who
was in the room
last week or the week before um she's
sort of treating them
like you treat one of your kids when
they're having a temper tantrum and she
has young kids
you humor it you allow them to say the
thing they want to say
and then you move on while showing that
it's not really something mommy is
impressed with and that's the
that's the vibe i get from jen saki
during these moments
now after this failed peter ducey tries
again
apparently with a quote real question it
doesn't really go much better
it's almost sometimes when he's reading
his questions like he's struggling to
understand because the emphasis and the
syntax
seems strange i don't really know let's
take a look
quickly on immigration the governor of
tennessee says that he was asked and he
declined a biden administration request
to
house unaccompanied minors and in coming
days
or in recent days there have been some
reports that at least four planes
filled with unaccompanied minders landed
in his state some in the middle of the
night
can you explain what's going on there
well as we have been very clear about
children our objective is to unite these
unaccompanied children
children under the age of 18 with
families with sponsor families so
children
traveling through we're traveling
through have been traveling through
tennessee
uh they're simply on their way to unite
with relatives and sponsors to meet
sponsors in the state or just traveling
through tennessee
until they reach another destination to
unite with family members or
legal sponsors as you know
geographically it's
right in a place where it you know
there's a lot of states around it so
it's a place where some flights have
gone through as uh children are moving
to other destinations and since this was
something that the governor of the state
said he didn't want this is not
a case of federal officials trying to
sneak something past
the state level officials i think i'm
confirming here that
tennessee is a state that is right near
in the middle of the country and some
kids have to travel
through there to get through their
destination and we've been very clear
that our objective is to
treat these kids humanely get them to
safe homes especially
homes of loved ones and sponsored
families
this is an attempt at a new fake
scandal which is the tennessee governor
doesn't want
any of biden's migrant children
traveling through
the state of tennessee but the tennessee
governor was silent about this
when it was trump doing the same thing
ducey's question of course
ignores that relevant context and yet
some flights have stopped in tennessee
in moving migrant children around
these are government flights mostly
stopping mostly at government air bases
and ducey wants to gin up a controversy
that joe biden is ignoring the requests
of the tennessee governor
the reality is that a flight stopping in
tennessee
for people to change planes or to
reunite with their families who may be
living in tennessee it's not really the
spirit of what the tennessee governor is
even talking about and this is again
mostly the federal government using
their airplanes
and airport resources available at their
disposal
but it's supposed to be another scandal
and hilariously
they then moved on to this was being
done
secretly check out this headline from a
recent episode of hannity on fox news
called
biden administration secretly flying
migrant children into tennessee report
says
now again secretly when these are
government planes going to military
bases
airports at military bases is it secret
that it's just not like oh
it's united flight 5 from new york to la
uh to call it secret is also a stretch
it couldn't be more deceptive
the reality is that the biden
administration is
just like the trump administration
continuing to use geographically
convenient airports around the country
for layovers for children in their
custody
and the priority should be reuniting
those kids with their families which by
the way
the number of kids who have not yet been
reunited
is down 84 last month under the biden
administration it's not yet a victory
immigration has not been solved daca has
not been dealt with
but this is at least some progress from
what we were seeing under the trump
administration
administration the reuniting
of the children with their families
might most conveniently be done
in tennessee or with a layover in
tennessee it's very simple
everything is a scandal now and of
course unfortunately
none of them are really catching on as
scandals
uh but it doesn't matter because there's
this
general idea from the right if you watch
fox news
that joe biden is beleaguered and
riddled in scandal
individually none of the scandals really
catch on
but you still are starting to see
reflected in polling the idea that biden
is just
embroiled in scandal among fox news
viewers and republican voters so
this stuff works there's a reason why
they keep doing this stuff as you and i
might see it and say another fake
scandal this is trash
this is meaningless it actually does
work to convince a lot of people